foreign
[Music]
guys welcome back to tomes of Terror
doing another book review today
so a couple weeks ago I guess it was
I got an email from an author named Sean
Barber who was offering me an arc
Advanced reader's copy of his upcoming
horror Novella which is called the last
day and that book is going to be coming
out October 23rd 2023.
so of course like I said I'm all about
the free books uh so I accepted and
because it was shorter than the book
that I was already reading that I was
going to review this week
um I decided to push it up in the review
schedule because it would be quicker for
me to read it obviously so I went to his
Amazon author page uh apparently he's a
virginia-based writer although he's
originally from Florida which is also my
home state uh so I looked through all of
his stuff and it looks like
um he writes a lot of horror and fantasy
and a lot of them are kind of in several
volume series some of them kind of look
like graphic novels too but I'm not
really sure about that
um this one though the last day seems to
be a standalone story I think
um and I have to say that I actually
really dug it quite a bit
um if you want kind of like a ballpark
idea of what it's about it's kind of
like not necessarily a zombie scenario
but kind of like a viral apocalypse
scenario kind of like 28 Days Later The
Crazies or something like that
um that's kind of cross-bred with the
movie Groundhog Day with little bit of
like inter-dimensional weirdness thrown
in there as well and that's kind of like
like I said in the general area of what
the book is like so at the beginning of
the story we meet a man named Ron who is
like a personal injury lawyer you know
of the type that people usually
disparagingly call ambulance Chasers
like he's one of those
um he actually you know prior to the
events of the book like the night before
he had attended his high school reunion
I guess it was his 10-year High School
reunion and it so happened that he ended
up hooking up with an old Crush of his
name Cecilia like in the hotel room
where he was staying at now Cecilia is
married now but you know that apparently
didn't stop her from sampling a little
bit of Ron when the opportunity arose so
there you go now in The Cold Light of
morning however
Cecilia tells Ron in no uncertain terms
that she always wanted to have sex with
him like back in the day and is glad
that she finally got to she's not saying
that but this is just a one-time
situation uh she loves her husband whose
name is Tony and is absolutely going
back to him so Ron is like I guess he's
not really surprised by this you know
he's a little bit hurt by it I guess as
you would
um and he's also kind of bummed out
because at the reunion the night before
he kind of had the perception that his
other classmates like turned out more
successful than him and in particular
there was one named Jason who was like
this big time City lawyer and kind of
like looked down on him a little bit
just for being like I said like an
ambulance Chaser so he's like a little
bit bummed out about that too but he
does understand like the whole deal with
Cecilia he wasn't like hoping for a
relationship or anything like that so
he's just like okay I understand and she
ends up leaving the hotel room now
shortly afterward he leaves the hotel
like he checks out and he stops at a
coffee place on the way out of town
because he's going back because like I
said he had to go back to his hometown
for the for the reunion or whatever
so when he stops at this coffee place
though all [__] hell breaks loose
right a dude straight up drives his car
like Through the Windows of the coffee
shop and then he you know which wounds
several people and then the driver like
gets out of the car and he's just
giggling like a maniac and has some
really weird looking like yellow eyes
and then this crazy person
proceeds to beat the main character Ron
to death and no I did not misspeak and
that's not a spoiler either because this
all happens like literally in the first
like five pages of the story and it's
also revealed in the book synopsis
because I went to the Amazon page
because they have like a pre-order thing
on there and it's in the synopsis so I'm
not ruining anything for you I promise
so basically after this startling
development of the main character
getting beaten to death in the first
couple of pages
run wakes up back in the hotel room with
Cecilia and it seems as though the same
day is beginning to repeat itself
now at first Ron just thinks he had like
a terrible nightmare the night before as
you would but similar [__] keeps on
happening like no matter how hard he
tries to alter events like to do
something different whenever like
wherever he goes on that day
he is eventually attacked by different
giggling nut cases with like the same
yellow eyes and as The Story Goes On It
starts to become pretty clear that some
kind of worldwide epidemic of like
homicidal Madness I guess is starting to
overtake the world's population it seems
and not only that but Ron appears to be
the only person who's kind of like
trapped in this Purgatory where he keeps
reliving the same day over and over
again but he can't figure out why you
know what I mean so he knows what's
gonna happen he knows that this
um that this plague is coming and [__]
like that and so he tries to do
different things or you know see it's oh
maybe this was a dream and maybe it's
not really going to happen but then it
just keeps happening but like in
different ways but he can't really
figure out like why he seems to be the
only one that's experiencing this so the
bulk of the story then is Ron kind of
slowly coming to the realization of what
exactly might be happening like to him
and to the World At Large and trying to
figure out a way to stop it if he can
stop it or at least kind of free himself
from the time Loop now like a lot of
stories with this kind of thing like
this kind of Trope there is a tendency
toward repetition
um you know that's just kind of an
occupational hazard when you're writing
about this kind of thing because Ron
does keep getting killed in various ways
and then waking up back in the hotel
room again like this that same morning
and having like similar exchanges with
Cecilia and all that kind of stuff but
honestly I'm gonna say that I think it
was really well handled here
um I think there's plenty of variation
in the scenarios like as they unfold
that the recurring events didn't really
wear out their welcome because other
than him like waking up and being like
oh [__] here I am again and talking to
Cecilia for a couple of minutes like
usually he tries to do something
different like every day and it always
ends up having a different outcome so it
wasn't like super repetitive in that
regard so like I said I think it was
really well handled
um and as soon as Ron kind of clues in
to what's happening and like I said
starts making alterations on the routine
oh today I'm going to try to get in my
mom's house and see and try and save her
today I'm gonna you know be a little bit
later to the coffee shop and see if you
know what I mean so he tries to like do
different things
um so it's it's so it's not like the
exact same incidents playing out over
and over again like the results are
drastically different every time like
they always begin the same way and they
always kind of end with him dying but
it's always like a different person that
attacks him so it's always like you know
so it's he keeps it like mixed up you
know what I'm saying so as I mentioned I
really enjoyed this book quite a bit
um Ron was kind of like a sort of a hang
dog like every man type of protagonist
but as the story began to unfold and he
started to figure out what was going on
he really kind of had to like tap into
his like intelligence a little bit in
his fortitude
um to try to finagle his way out of this
predicament that he found himself in for
whatever reason and I will admit I'm not
gonna spoil it but um I didn't really
guess what the ultimate cause of the
outbreak was gonna be
um because it's a little bit unusual
it's not like something that you would
normally see like in a you know like in
a zombie movie or something or even like
a virus type movie it's it's kind of not
like that so I like that he went like a
different direction with it
um now the thing that sort of caused it
it isn't really explained to any great
degree like it is kind of but it's not
you know it's not really gone into but
honestly I think that was for the best I
think that you as the reader find out as
much about the situation as Ron did and
that's it like you don't find out any
more than that and I think you know and
I'm sure I've mentioned this like on
many occasions before I always think
it's better to like under explain than
over explain and so I think this was
really well done because if you were it
puts you in Ron's shoes and it's like if
this happened to you then obviously you
know you're only learning as much as he
learns and no more than that there's not
like a lot of exposition and I thought
that was really good even though you're
just kind of like what the [__] [__]
like why like why is this happening and
stuff but I think it's better to kind of
just leave it ambiguous I like that
better you know so yeah if you like
apocalypse style like horror fiction and
kind of want to read something that has
maybe like a little bit more of a
metaphysical or mind [__] kind of angle
to it
um then this would probably be right up
your alley I'm gonna say I think that if
you liked movies like triangle for
example like the one about the cruise
ship that was kind of like a Time Loop
like um this it didn't remind me of that
but sort of you know what I mean it's
kind of in the same ballpark like I said
um this is I I found this quite well
written and it's very fast paced and it
has some good Gore scene sprinkled like
some pretty [__] up [__] happens in it
too so I thought that was pretty awesome
so like I said this isn't out yet as of
this recording it'll be out on October
23rd you can actually go to Amazon and
pre-order it if you want to do that and
I actually would recommend it like I
said if you like that kind of Apocalypse
style horror because this was actually
like a really good one that's not super
super long I think it's about 175 Pages
something like that so you know you can
get through it but I think it would be
like a really good read for Halloween
and it'll be out like a week before
Halloween so you should definitely uh go
and check it out and I would really like
to thank Sean Barber for sending me the
Arc of it that was really cool so that
will do it for this tomes of Terror hope
to see you guys again on the next one
remember to like share subscribe and all
of that and I'll see you again on the
next one bye